[Music]
there's no key to success but the key to
failure is trying to please everyone so
just do you
I always can't try and put myself in
situations like I've always tried to
make records that I want to listen to
like people always say do you make music
for your fan base and I go no like like
if I made music for my fan base like I
wouldn't be happy I'd be making music to
appease someone else the reason I create
music and play music is essentially to
make myself happy I feel like that's why
anyone creates
you might never be the best at something
but you can always work harder than
someone who is the best
I came into an industry where I am not
the most talented person in my industry
but I know I can outwork everyone
because that that's the one thing I can
do I think I just think being yourself
is so powerful and I feel like a
beautiful person without the sounding
weird about it but because of it I have
now confidence in myself because of
being myself all of these great things
have happened so now I can walk into an
award show dressed however I want and be
super confident about it because it's
like I've done what I could say how to
achieve without compromising you're
allowed to be artistic and don't let
anyone dim your light like you should
always shine as bright as that but it's
about instilling confidence in people
and I think me having success
I can say to her look I was really weird
and I've managed to have success so if
you just carry on doing you you're going
to have the same thing
if you fail you've not lost anything and
if you achieve and make it good the
possibilities are endless
everything leads up to a point and
there's steps that you have to take
basically and just remind yourself of
the steps
should I do this should I not do this ah
I'm just gonna experience it
of course I'm insecure everyone I know
is insecure I think successful people
are overly insecure because you have
people kind of poking holes in you the
whole time
I think because I most men that I know
were insecure but for fear of being
called a precious little snowflake would
never say anything and my dad always
said to me like if you don't need to get
a degree to do a job then go out and
experience it like you know if you want
to be a doctor go and get your grades
and stuff but if you want to be a
musician your education is going to come
from doing shows writing songs
practicing meeting people networking so
I just start off as early as possible
and do that
theory about the ten thousand dollars
theories when I first started out I saw
Damien Rice in concert I mentioned it in
a song I said I won't stop till my names
in lights Stadium Heights with Damian
Rice and literally like I watched him
and was like I want to do that one day
and wrote a million songs did a million
gigs ended up kind of doing
a similar thing but it literally came
from writing a song a day or two songs a
day or five songs a day and just getting
all these songs out of me doing a
million gigs sometimes three gigs a day
sometimes we did six gigs a day one year
at Glastonbury but I think
is you view it as a dirty tap when you
switch a dirty tap on it's going to
float [ __ ] water out for a substantial
amount of time and then clean water is
going to start flowing and now and then
you'll get a bit but as long as it gets
out of you it's fine so with songs
you're going to write songs at the
beginning you want my songs were
terrible my raps would say like I've
listened to it the other day it's awful
but I got it out of me and the more and
more you write the more and more you
experience and then you start flowing
clean water and songs start getting
better and better and better and when
you just you're on a good streak you're
writing good songs now and then you're
going to write a [ __ ] song and that song
is out of you and you can move on
and it's the same with gigs like you
will always play Bad gigs at the
beginning that's what you need to do and
then
the more gigs you do the better you'll
get now and then you'll have a [ __ ] gig
but that's all right because you've got
it out of you and you've experienced it
so I just say the more and more you can
do you put in your 10 000 hours
write as many songs as possible gig as
much as possible always be nice to
people because that is how the music
industry works now it doesn't work on
who's the best it works on who's got the
best music and who's the nicest
the key is not not to be swept up I'm an
artist but I'm still a human being I'm
not I'm not a prop star you know I'm
still I'm still a normal guy that grew
up in the countryside and as all my
friends are still the same I drive a
Mini Cooper shop in the same Supermarket
I feel like the moment you lose that you
start losing your your audience because
people can't people can't relate to you
so you you just have to you have to be
human
when people say artists are born with
Talent you're not you have to really
learn and really practice
I've I've always had an ethos with of
just working harder than anyone else
that I in my own respect and
being trying to betray and be nice
my dad always told me choose someone you
admire and work harder than and be be
nice to them
I don't know there's a few things but
someone said something to me the other
day when I was in the studio and he said
dare to suck which I thought was a
really really good thing where you're
not afraid to fail I think that's a
really good thing for a musician to have
so yeah dare to suck basically I I want
to stress the point that it's not
stuttering is not is not a thing you
have to be worried about at all and even
if you have quirks and weirdness you
shouldn't be worried about that the
people that I went to school with that
were the most normal and were the
coolest when we grew up like I was
telling Emily earlier that uh one of the
cool kids from school now does my
Plumbing so that's that's a flex that's
a fact so um my thing that I wanted to
stress most tonight is not necessarily
to shed light on stuttering or make it
or make it a thing it's just
um stress to kids in in in in general is
it just be yourself because there's no
one in the world that can be a better
you than you and if you try to be the
cool kid from class you'll end up being
very boring and doing Plumbing for
someone and yeah it's just be yourself
embrace your quirks being weird is a it
is is is is is a wonderful thing
my goals and dreams I've said this a
million times my golden dreams are
always to play Shepherd's Bush Empire
and have a gold album and with the week
the album came out we played Shepard's
Empire and the album went gold and then
from there it's just kind of gone
so it's quite easy for me to be myself
because I've been every every step of
the way every time I be myself I've had
success in it but I think it's hard when
you've had a lot of success musically
maybe doing something that you didn't
believe in 100 you know sometimes the
success that you find isn't actually you
being yourself but also I think it's the
fake it so you make it attitude of if
you let people think you're successful
then you will eventually become
successful
my pain might be different to someone
else's it might not be on the scale of
of anyone else's but it still creates
music
I don't really see the point of making
music if it's not an expression of self
or a form of therapy you know it's like
if I have a bad day I want to write a
song
I don't want to write a song to have a
hit I want to write a song because I
want it to make me feel better when
you're anger is something you write
either an email or a letter to that
person and then you just write
everything down and then you don't give
it to them it's just about getting it
out and it just makes you feel better
you just you have it you read it you rip
it up you're done all creatives are
prone to real ups and downs because you
have a part of your brain that you open
to write a song that you let these
really personal emotions out to write
the song but then that part doesn't
close sometimes so you are just you ha
you feel so much and you are up and down
and up and down and my Highs are really
high but my lows are really really low
and I got really low and realized that
the thing that made me happy was writing
songs and getting those feelings out
again
I find I've been working on it for the
past eight eight years and whether it be
getting rid of a phone and only
answering emails like you know twice a
day or whether it's like cutting down my
friendship group to the bare minimum
just so I trust everyone although
whether it's living in the countryside
in the middle of nowhere and kind of
closed off a bit from reality I think
all of these little things are in place
to protect this my mind and it's all
working I think
Fame is it is an enhancer of anything
that is going on if you have an ego you
get a bigger ego if you're anxious you
get more anxious if you're shy you get
more shy
I look at my dad and my dad has four
friends now and they're like his core
friends and he probably had 20 friends
when he was 20 or 25 but the older you
get the smaller your friendship group
shrinks and fame just speeds that up it
just enhances that so my friendship
group has shrunk but I'm left with the
people that I'd have been left with in
20 years anyway so yeah I have changed
I've learned a lot I don't care what
people think like I'm so happy with
where I am I love my friends I love my
wife I love my family
no one's to celebrate the success with
like what's what's the point so I'd say
the greatest success has been settling
I want a 30-year career not a five-year
career I don't I don't want to do it all
up you know we could have done stadiums
a lot early on we could have done Arenas
a lot earlier on we could have released
Five albums in five years but it's it's
a marathon not a Sprint and I remember
being around a lot of my contemporaries
that were doing so much better than me
and my manager being like slow down just
slow down slow down and now I'm still
here six years on and they're not and I
think you like
the whole music industry you just need
to just pace yourself just take time to
make great albums you don't you don't
have to stick out music all the time to
stay relevant you'll stay relevant by
making great records and to make great
records you have to spend a lot of time
to do
if you don't aim for the top of the
mountain how are you ever going to get
halfway
[Music]